Ladies and gentlemen, here are 10 things
that are truly awesome.
Imagine, if you will, having to schlep
everything on your back.
Wouldn't this be easier for me
if I could roll this home?
Yes, so I think I'll invent the wheel.
The wheel, ladies and gentlemen.
Is the wheel awesome? Say it with me.
Yes, the wheel is awesome!
The Great Pyramids were the tallest
man-made structure in the world
for 4,000 years.
Pharaoh had his slaves move millions of blocks
just to this site to erect a big freaking headstone.
Were the Great Pyramids awesome?
Yes, the pyramids were awesome.
The Grand Canyon. Come on.
It's almost 80 million years old.
Is the Grand Canyon awesome?
Yes, the Grand Canyon is.
Louis Daguerre invented photography in 1829,
and earlier today,
when you whipped out your smartphone
and you took a shot of your awesome sandwich,
and you know who you are —
(Laughter) —
wasn't that easier than exposing the image
to copper plates coated with iodized silver?
I mean, come on. Is photography awesome?
Yes, photography is awesome.
D-Day, June 6, 1944,
the Allied invasion of Normandy,
the largest amphibious invasion in world history.
Was D-Day awesome? Yes, it was awesome.
Did you eat food today? Did you eat?
Then you can thank the honeybee, that's the one,
because if crops aren't pollinated, we can't grow food,
and then we're all going to die.
It's just like that.
But it's not like a flower can just get up
and have sex with another flower,
although that would be awesome.
(Laughter)
Bees are awesome. Are you kidding me?
Landing on the moon! Come on!
Apollo 11. Are you kidding me?
Sixty-six years after the Wright Brothers
took off from Kitty Hawk, North Carolina,
Neil Armstrong was 240,000 miles away.
That's like from here to the moon.
(Laughter)
That's one small step for a man,
one giant leap for awesome!
You're damn right, it was.
Woodstock, 1969: Rolling Stone Magazine said
this changed the history of rock and roll.
Tickets were only 24 dollars back then.
You can't even buy a freaking t-shirt for that now.
Jimi Hendrix's version of "The Star-Spangled Banner"
was the most iconic.
Was Woodstock awesome? Yes, it was awesome.
Sharks! They're at the top of the food chain.
Sharks have multiple rows of teeth
that grow in their jaw
and they move forward like a conveyor belt.
Some sharks can lose 30,000 teeth in their lifetime.
Does awesome inspire fear?
Oh, hell yeah, sharks are awesome!
The Internet was born in 1982
and it instantly took over global communication,
and later tonight, when all these PowerPoints
are uplifted to the Internet
so that a guy in Siberia can get drunk
and watch this crap,
the Internet is awesome.
And finally, finally some of you can't wait
to come up and tell me how awesome my PowerPoint was.
I will save you the time.
It was not awesome, but it was true,
and I hope it was entertaining,
and out of all the audiences I've ever had,
y'all are the most recent. Thank you and good night.
(Applause)